>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Jason Steinhauer:
Well good afternoon.
My name is Jason Steinhauer
and I'm a program specialist
for the John W. Kluge Center
at the Library of Congress.
Before we begin today's
program, please take a moment
to check your cell phones
and other electronic devices
and please set them to silent.
Thank you.
I'd also like to make you aware
that this afternoon's program
is being filmed for placement
on the Kluge Center website as well
as on our YouTube and
iTunes channels.
I encourage you to
visit our website,
LOC.gov/Kluge to view
other lectures delivered
by current and past Kluge scholars.
Today's lecture is presented
by the John W. Kluge Center
at the Library of Congress.
The Kluge Center is a vibrant
scholar center on Capitol Hill
that brings together scholars and
researchers from around the world
to stimulate and energize one
another, to distill wisdom
from the library's rich
resources and to interact
with policy makers and the public.
The center offers opportunities
for senior scholars,
post-doctoral fellows and PhD
candidates to conduct research
in the library's collections.
We also offer free public
lectures such as this one.
Conferences, symposia, book talks,
roundtables, many other programs,
and we administer the Kluge Prize
which recognized outstanding
achievement
in the humanities and
social sciences.
For more information
about the Kluge Center,
please do visit our
website, LOC.gov/Kluge.
I also invite you to sign up for
our email alerts, and you will learn
about future programs and you will
also learn about opportunities
for you to conduct your own
research here at the library.
Today's program is titled
Making Patriotic Prostitutes:
The South Korean Government's
Policies
on Prostitution for the US Military.
It features scholar Jeong-Mi
Park, currently a Kluge fellow
at the John W. Kluge Center.
Dr. Park's research at the library
examines how the South Korean
government controlled
military prostitutes catering
to American servicemen in the
context of US military occupation,
the hot and cold wars, economic
development and globalization.
She also reveals the ways in
which the Korean government strove
to make these "dangerous"
women into "patriotic subjects"
who could contribute
to national security.
Jeong-Mi Park earned her BA, MA and
PhD at the Department of Sociology,
Seoul National University.
She worked as a research assistant
professor at Hanyang University
as a historical sociologist.
She has analyzed the historical
transformations of state policies,
citizenship and social
movements in South Korea
from a perspective of
gender and sexuality.
The title of her PhD dissertation
is A Study on Prostitution Policies
in Korea: The Transformation of
the Toleration Regulation Regime
and the Historical Constitution
of the Prostitute, 1945-2005.
She has published several papers in
Women's Studies International Forum,
Korean Journal of Sociology
and Society and History.
And most recently she has
been a Kluge fellow here
at the Library of Congress.
So please join me in
welcoming Jeong-Mi Park.
[ Applause ]
>> Jeong-Mi Park: Thank you
everyone for coming to my talk.
It was my honor to conduct
research at the Library
of Congress as a Kluge Fellow.
And I am glad to express my
appreciation to the people
who made my stay amazing.
Dr. Recker of the Kluge Center,
Janice Hyde, the former director
of scholars, and the wonderful
staff such as Marylou,
Joanne, Travis, Jason and Ben.
My colleagues, Kluge fellows,
the promising young scholars,
outstanding senior scholars
and many people and librarians.
And I also appreciate my
husband Ti-Won and my friend Ken
for their valuable discussions.
My project is a history of
sociology of prostitution policies
in post-colonial South Korea.
After World War II, Korea's sex
industry was divided according
to the race or nationality of the
client, such as Korean nationals,
American troops and foreign
forces, most of who were Japanese.
In order to control those
racially regulated sex industries,
the Korean government implemented
separate but similar policies.
In my book I'm exploring how
such policies were intertwined
with Korea's ongoing
nation-building process.
Today I will focus on
one of those policies,
the evolution of the Korean
government control of prostitution
for the US military
since World War II.
And the way in which it
was developed and enforced
in the name of national security.
I would like to begin my
talk with a comment made
by an American medical officer
who visited South Korea
right after World War II.
He was brigadier general and an
advisor for health and welfare
to the US army forces
in South Korea.
In his autobiography entitled Medic,
he recalled his first
impression of the Korean people.
And I quote, "Korean
women as a matter
of national pride apparently
had refrained from social
and sexual contacts with their
occupiers during the 30 years
of Japanese occupation.
When the American soldiers moved
into Korea in the fall of 1945,
the Korean girls would have
nothing to do with them.
In fact the first girls who
were seen in the company
of American soldiers were
shunned by the Korean people
who had protected their
women from sexual contact
with Japanese for so many years."
On one hand, his observation
was accurate
since Korean women's sexuality
had been considered a matter
of national pride and strictly
suppressed for a long time.
On the other hand, he was wrong in
that the Korean people had failed
to protect their women,
although they despised those
who catered to their occupiers.
In fact, in the late 19th century,
Japanese settlers transplanted
a system
of legalized prostitution
to the Korean peninsula.
Before this prostitution in
Korea had been prohibited
by the Joseon Dynasty, though it was
not always successfully enforced.
With prostitution legalized,
some disenfranchises Korean girls
and women were legally or
illegally trafficked to brothels
to serve both Japanese
and Korean men.
This picture shows the first brothel
district in Seoul in the 1910's.
The next one shows the inside of
a brothel in Gunsan in the 1930's.
This was until 1931 when Japan
invaded North China, numerous girls
and women from throughout east
Asia were mobilized by force
or misrepresentation into
serving as comfort women
for the Japanese military.
How many women were
recruited is not clear.
Scholars speculate that their
numbers were between 50,000-200,000
and Korean women constituted
a substantial part of them.
These pictures show
Korean comfort women
who were rescued by
the Allied forces.
At the time of [inaudible],
a new and different chapter
of Korean female sexual contact
with foreigners was about to begin.
Let's go back to Sam's memoir.
He continued, "Time passed.
With the usual gifts of candy and
other things, the initial resistance
of Korean women to association with
foreign soldiers was broken down.
A comparatively small segment
of the Korean population then
became highly infected as far
as [inaudible] was concerned,
by the American soldiers.
And in turn passed the
infection on to other soldiers.
It does not take long."
Although Sam did not
mention the word explicitly,
these women associating with
American servicemen were seen
to be prostitutes by
both Korean society
and the US military in Korea.
Then how did the newly
arrived troops grapple
with prostitution and STD's?
What kind of policies
did they rely on?
In order to answer this
question, it is necessary to go
over the two legacies
that had an impact
on post-colonial Korea's policies.
Colonial regulation and
American prohibition.
As I said before, Japanese
settlers started legalizing
prostitution Korea.
In 1916, the colonial government
promulgated a series of regulations
to centralize prostitution
nationwide.
Which were tighter regulation of
brothel owners and prostitutes,
and regulation of geishas,
[inaudible]
and employers of geishas.
So first the regulation
legalized prostitution
by registering prostitutes and
subjecting them to STD examinations.
These licensed prostitutes
were called public prostitutes.
The second regulation
applied to Geishas
and Korean [inaudible] and barmaids.
In 1937 another category was added.
These women were not
public prostitutes.
So in principle, prostitution of
these groups was prohibited by law.
Nevertheless, the colonial
government also enforced
registration and STD testing
of such women on the premise
that they were likely to
engage in prostitution.
In this way the prostitution
policies
in colonial Korea were
composed of two pillars.
I call the first one the
authorization regulation policy,
and the second one the
toleration regulation policy.
The Japanese military's
occupation system before
and during World War
II was an extreme form
of these authorization regulations
in that the Japanese military
and imperial government
not only established
and managed confrontations
for servicemen,
but also urbanized the
mobilization of comfort of women.
In contrast, the United States
adopted the opposite approach
towards prostitution in
the early 20th century.
That is, prohibition.
As this map shows, by 1942 all
states except for the four shown
in white had laws against
prostitution.
In addition, in 1941 the federal
government enacted the so-called May
Act to suppress prostitution
near military bases.
At the same time, the United States
implemented extensive STD control
policies, in particular
during the two World Wars.
Women, including professional
prostitutes and so-called amateurs,
were considered a source of STD's.
As you can see from these
posters from the US military,
[inaudible] were represented
with demonized female figures.
Military police and public
officials had authority to identify,
locate and apprehend
women who were suspected
of transmitting STD's
to military personnel.
This was called a contact
tracing program.
This picture shows a
contact tracing interview
between a military medical officer
and an infected serviceman
during World War II.
The arrested women were incarcerated
in detention centers for weeks
or even months until
they were cured.
This photo shows a detention
center during World War II
which was called a
rapid treatment center.
By contrast, from 1944 infected
soldiers did not receive any
disciplinary actions or punishment.
In this respect, despite
substantial differences,
not only colonial regulation, but
also American prohibition was a form
of oppression of women in that both
of them regarded women not
men as the source of STD's.
And strictly controlled the women.
And post-colonial Korea
became a stage
on which these two policies
encountered each other.
Two days after the US
Army's occupation of Korea
on September 8th, 1945, the United
States Army Military Government
in Korea was established.
The new military governor struggled
to safeguard the servicemen
from STD's.
In May 1946 he proclaimed an
ordinance to punish women with STD's
for "engaging in or eliciting
sexual intercourse with any member
of the occupying forces."
What is interesting here is that
the US Military Government in Korea,
unlike in the United States,
criminalized not prostitution
but the spread of STD's.
Edward Grand Mead, an officer
of the US Military Government
in Korea pointed out
this contradictory nature
of the prostitution
policy as follows.
"In a sense, the attitude
of military government towards this
profession had an amusing facet.
No attempt was made to
illegalize the practice,
and a Korean prostitute was not
disobeying the law unless she
engaged in sexual intercourse
with any member
of the occupying forces
while suffering
from [inaudible] in
an infectious state."
At the same time the military
government retained the colonial
requirement of registration and
testing, as this document shows.
"A policy has been set up that all
entertainment girls will be required
to have vaginal and seriological
examinations every month.
Failure to have such examinations
will result in the loss of license."
On the contrary, Korean
feminists struggled
to abolish the colonial regulation.
To many Koreans, state regulated
prostitution was a symbolic reminder
of our shameful colonial past.
In early 1947, female activists
proposed a bill entitled Act
on the Abolishment of
Legalized Prostitution.
The legislature passed it
with only one dissenting vote,
showing its agreement with
feminists that abolition stood
for a new nation free
of colonial vestiges.
Following the American model, the
new law prohibited prostitution,
criminalizing all participants
in the sex industry.
It is ironic that American
prohibition was introduced not
by the US military government but by
the Korean people who were striving
to eliminate colonial vestiges.
As a result of this new law, public
prostitutes lost their legal status
and were subject to punishment
if they persisted in their work.
Nevertheless, this
new law was not enough
to uproot all colonial vestiges
since it only abolished regulation
of public prostitutes,
leaving intact regulation
of geishas, barmaids and waitresses.
Moreover, two weeks before the
effective date of the new law,
the military government enacted a
regulation called Establish the Rule
on the Business of Entertainers,
retolerating the colonial regulation
of geishas, barmaids and waitresses
who are simply recategorized
as entertainers.
This rule continued the registration
and testing requirements.
Consequently, even though
prostitution was entirely prohibited
by the new law, these females,
these workers were still subject
to regulation on the assumption
that they were likely to engage
in prostitution as in
the colonial period.
In this way, toleration
regulation survived regulation
and was renewed while authorization
regulation was abolished
by the new prohibitionist law.
I call the combination
of colonial regulation
and American prohibition the
toleration regulation regime.
Interestingly, Korean feminists
did not challenge this toleration
regulation regime, even though
it retained the colonial legacy.
Rather they actually supported it.
On one hand they adhered
to prohibition
in order to build a moral nation.
On the other hand, they also
demanded more rigorous STD testing
of women likely to engage
in prostitution in order
to protect the new
nation from STD's.
In this respect the toleration
regulation regime was more
than a lingering colonial legacy.
It was a post colonial reinvention
that enabled a compromise
between Korean feminists and
the US Military Government.
They shared the interest of
combating STD's for their nation
and for their servicemen,
respectively.
After the Korean government
was established in 1948,
the US military withdrew from Korea,
leaving only 500 military advisors.
At the time of the
Korean War however,
foreign troops including
Americans returned,
and prostitution for them resumed.
During the Korean War, the
peak strength of UN forces
from 21 countries was 340,000
of which the vast majority,
300,000 were Americans.
In order to comfort these allies,
the Korean government permitted
comfort stations to be established.
According to one document I found
at the Korean National Archive,
in October 1951 the Ministry of
Health instructed its officials
to license comfort stations.
This document specified that the
purpose of the facilities was
to protect the Korean
people's safety in order
that the service be offered only
to UN forces, not to civilians.
It also stipulated the registration
of comfort women, geishas
and waitresses in order to
conduct periodic STD testing.
The category of comfort women
was defined as "women who comfort
and entertain foreign
troops at comfort stations."
In this way the Korean
government returned
to authorization regulation
during the war.
Nonetheless, it was keenly aware
that licensing military brothels
was a violation of its own law.
In this document the Korean
government instructed its officials
to keep in mind that a comfort
station is "A special business
for conducting this
war, not a local one."
UN forces cooperated with the
Korean government policies well.
According to the same document,
a comfort station was established
when UN forces demanded it.
And the UN military police assisted
the Korean police in arresting women
who evaded registration
and STD testing.
Moreover, in a document of UNCACK,
or UN Civil Assistance Command
to Korea, similar categories of
women appeared as the targets
of registration and STD testing.
Prostitutes, dancers and waitresses.
UNCACK was responsible for directing
and assisting the Korean government
in enforcing public health
policies during the Korean War,
including the prevention of STD's.
Therefore it is possible
that the word prostitutes
in this document was an English
translation of Korean comfort women.
The frequency of check-ups was
twice a week for prostitutes,
once a week for dancers and
once a month for waitresses.
In this document the
UNCACK stipulated that
"If necessary the American medical
police will help the South Korean
police in conducting
this operation."
As we already know, the
terms comfort stations
and comfort women originated
from the Japanese military
sanctioned slavery before
and during World War II.
Korean government officials used the
same terms to refer to prostitutes
and military brothels for UN forces.
They also shared with the Japanese
the idea that it was necessary
to provide safe sex to the military
in order to boost soldiers' morale,
prevent STD's and protect so-called
ordinary women from sexual assault.
In a sense it is not
surprising given the fact
that the Korean War broke out only
five years after World War II ended.
And that most Korean government
officials having been trained
under colonial rule were familiar
with the Japanese policies.
However, historical documents
indicate that comfort stations
for UN troops were
established and managed
in a manner somewhat different
from the Japanese ones.
First, the Japanese
military directly established
and managed comfort stations or
ordered civilians to establish
and managed them following
its regulations.
According to this document
produced by the Allied forces right
after World War II, which
was entitled Amenities
in the Japanese Armed Forces,
such military regulation
on comfort stations were meticulous,
specifying almost everything
from rates to service hours to terms
of employment of comfort women.
Civilian managers were forced to
submit monthly business reports
to the military and
were not able to shut
down their business
without permission.
In this respect, the Japanese
comfort stations were de facto
military facilities directly
controlled by the Japanese military.
In fact, they were also often
called "filled army canteens."
In contrast, the Korean
government's regulation
of conversations was
much simpler and looser,
requiring only licensing the
facility and registration
and STD testing of comfort women.
In short, the Japanese comfort
stations were operated according
to strict military standards while
the Korean comfort stations were
in between military facilities
and civilian brothels.
Another important difference is
that while the Japanese government
and military were involved in
the recruitment and transport
of comfort women, there
is no evidence
that shows the Korean government
or UN forces did the same.
Finally the scale of comfort women
for UN troops was far smaller
than those for the
Japanese military.
Most researchers estimate
their number
between 50,000 to over 200,000.
By contrast, according
to the USCACK document,
right after the Korean War,
the number of registered
prostitutes was 9,233.
It can be assumed that these
differences between the Japanese
and Korean comfort stations
resulted from the characteristics
of each war and each government.
The history of the Japanese military
comfort stations traces back
to Japan's invasion of
north China in 1931,
continuing until the
end of World War II.
The number of Japanese
military reached 3 million
across the Pacific right
before the end of the war.
By contrast, as I previously
noted, the peak strength
of UN forces during the
Korean War was 340,000.
That was about a tenth
of the Japanese counterpart
during World War II.
The Korean government, which
was newly established in 1948
and thereafter devastated
by the war, was much weaker
and more chaotic than the
Japanese imperial government.
In addition, unlike
in Imperial Japan,
prostitution was outlawed
in post-colonial Korea.
Therefore it might have been
difficult for the Korean government
to overtly mobilize its own
women into comfort stations.
These pictures show
brothels or so-called houses
of ill repute established
during the Korean War.
Considering that these houses were
set up inside the Pacific area
and that their signs
were written in English,
they appear to be comfort
stations for UN forces.
Such a brothel was
equipped with a waiting room
and several bedrooms
with numbered doors.
This picture shows a Korean
doctor examining prostitutes
at a field clinic that belonged
to the Third US Infantry Division.
In a letter sent to UNCACK in 1951,
the chief of Korean police
explained the purpose of STD testing
of prostitutes and other
female entertainers as follows.
"This medical examination and
medical treatment for those who need
such assistance will be enforced
in order to promote the efforts
of the UN forces gallantly
fighting this war of aggression.
No misunderstanding
should therefore arise
from such action taken
by the police."
This letter implies that the Korean
police considered it necessary
to protect the health of
the UN forces and possibly
to provides safe pleasure
to them to help win the war.
However the UN forces did not
seem to be fully satisfied
with the Korean government's
STD control.
In the view of the UNCACK,
there was a glaring weakness
in the STD policy during
the war that is,
"The failure to isolate infected
individuals until noninfectious.
Prostitutes return to work
immediately after examination."
In order to overcome this
shortcoming, facilities to isolate
and treat infected prostitutes were
established not long after the war.
The Korean War ended in 1953, but
the US, motivated by the Cold War,
desired to contain communism,
maintained a sizeable
presence in Korea.
But the US military operated
under the name of the UN Command
when the other UN members
withdrew in the 1950's and '60's.
The number of American
military personnel decreased
from around 300,000 right after
the war to 58,000 in 1961.
And this level continued
throughout the 1960's.
The Korean government absolutely
depended upon the US military
for its national security
and was ready to do anything
to meet its allies requirements.
With the US military's long-term
presence, so-called compounds
which means business
and amusement area
around the US military
bases, started to form.
These pictures show what
the compounds looked
like in their early days.
The images of bustling streets,
clubs which the provost marshal
permitted his soldiers to enter.
The inside of such clubs and the
women who frequented these places.
During the Korean War
the government was able
to justify establishing
comfort stations in the name
of the state of emergency.
However, since the comfort stations
obviously violating the existing law
prohibiting prostitution,
the government had to shut
down those facilities
right after the war.
Replacing the comfort stations,
clubs became the main
venue of prostitution.
The Korean government also
licensed and regulated these clubs,
calling them "special
restaurants for UN troops."
With this euphemistic term,
the Korean government attempted
to avoid the allegation of
permitting prostitution.
In this way, after the Korean
War, the government returned
to the toleration regulation regime,
officially prohibiting prostitution
but simultaneously
tolerating and regulating it.
And during the Cold War,
the toleration regulation
regime became more systematized.
It was composed of several elements.
The fist element was zoning.
Regions were segregated areas
for the exclusive use
of American servicemen.
As this picture shows, Koreans
other than those catering
to the US military were not
allowed to enter these clubs.
The second was registration.
The Korean government
registered individual prostitutes
and issued certificates to them.
This certificate functioned
as a kind of ID card
for so-called entertainers to
prove that they were registered
and got regular STD checkups.
As during the Korean War,
entertainers were classified
into three groups: comfort
women, dancers and waitresses.
In this way the legal category
of comfort women survived while
comfort stations disappeared.
In the 1970's, the term
comfort women was replaced
by "special business girls".
All entertainers were forced to put
their photos on the certificates
to get a certificate stamp
when they got examinations
and to carry it while working.
Korean government statistics
indicate that as many
as 10,000 women may have
engaged in prostitution
for the US military
annually between the end
of the Korean War and
the late 1980's.
The third was regular STD testing.
The frequency of examination was
the same as during the Korean War.
Twice a week for comfort
women, once a week for dancers
and once a month for waitresses.
These three elements
of zoning, registration
and STD testing were carried
over from colonial regulation.
Added to these were the
following three elements taken
from American prohibition.
The first was the contact
tracing program.
From the post-World War II
occupation until the Korean War,
the US military tried to
implement this program
that it had utilized
in its own country.
However, this concentration program
was initially unsuccessful due
to the lack of effective
enforcement.
After the Korean War the contact
tracing program was stepped up.
This is an excerpt from a 1955
document of the Eighth US Army,
which describes how the
program was carried out.
"If the contact lives
in a nearby area,
appropriate military police
authorities will be notified
and then accompanied by
national police will endeavor
to locate the contact and have
her examined and treated."
In this way, the contact tracing
program was implemented jointly
by the US military police and
the Korean National Police.
The women who were suspected
of spreading infection
to American servicemen or who did
not carry their health certificates
were arrested.
The next element was first treatment
so that the UNCACK recognized
the lack of facilities
for mandatory treatment
as a glaring weakness
in STD control during
the Korean War.
This problem was solved
with the establishment
of STD treatment centers in
camp towns during the 1960's.
It is noteworthy that
in the United States
such facilities were entirely closed
in the early 1950's
while they were newly set
up in Korea during the 1960's.
This is one of them which
was established in the 1960's
and shut down in the late 1990's.
The US military helped the
Korean government build
and manage these facilities
by offering financial
and medical resources.
The final element was prohibition.
As I previously noted, the Korean
government restored prohibition
right after the Korean War.
This prohibition was based
on the act of the abolishment
of legalized prostitution enacted in
1947, and the act on the prevention
of morally degrading behaviors,
which replaced the
former act in 1961.
Since prostitution was
illegally prohibited,
the Korean police had authority
to round up prostitutes.
But in general the
police focused not
on suppressing prostitution,
but on combatting STD's.
In this way, the toleration
regulation regime
that was systematized during
the cold war was a patchwork
of colonial regulation
and American prohibition.
As a result, prostitutes were
subject not only to zoning,
registration and STD testing, but
also to contact tracing programs,
first treatment in detention centers
and sporadic crackdowns
by the police.
Therefore the toleration regulation
regime can be considered one
of the most severe and intensive
policies [inaudible] prosecution
by combining every oppressive
element of both colonial regulation
and American prohibition.
The testimony of former military
prostitutes shows how harsh the
toleration regulation regime was.
This is the autobiography
of [inaudible]
who sexually served the US
military during the 1960's and '70's
and later became a
human rights activist.
This is what she said
as translated by me.
"At that time I did not know that
Korea prohibited prostitution.
After a few years, I was
so surprised to learn that.
Isn't it quite contradictory
that the government
prohibits prostitution
but at the same time
forcibly examines prostitutes
and prevents those with
STD's from working?
I have also been arrested and
detained at a police station
and subjected to some retrial.
Women who contracted gonorrhea or
other diseases were immediately sent
to a detention center, usually a
village surrounded by mountains.
It was cold monkey house.
Every woman hated living
at the monkey house.
Being treated like criminals,
we felt ashamed to be forced
to spread our legs every day
to determine whether we
were diseased or not."
This testimony shows that the
police rounded up prostitutes not
for the suppression of prostitution,
but for the control of STD's,
even though the prohibitionist
rule justified the roundups.
It also demonstrates that the
human rights of the women detained
at the STD detention treatment
centers were severely violated.
Other former military prostitutes
also testified that forced treatment
in detention centers was painful,
even causing death due
to penicillin shock.
The contact tracing program
and forced treatment were
so mercilessly carried out that
its subjects were terrorized.
For instance, if an American soldier
pointed out a woman as a carrier
of STD's, she was immediately
apprehended and incarcerated
at detention center,
regardless of whether
or not she actually infected him.
The Korean officials and camp town
women, often called the [inaudible],
which means clearing the
enemies in Korean, took them.
Then how was the Korean
government able
to implement those two
seemingly contradictory policies
of prohibition and regulation
simultaneously in the form
of the toleration regulation regime?
In fact, prohibition was
based on laws that were passed
by the legislature while regulation
was implemented through rules,
orders and local ordinances that
the other administrators could enact
without the legislature's
rectification.
In this system, regulation
of prohibition
and in turn both the regulation
and prohibition suspended
basic rights guaranteed
by the constitution,
such as arrest warrants,
the right of legal counsel
and the right to trial.
The Korean Constitution
specifies that the restriction
of personal freedom
should be based on law.
Therefore in principle
the STD control
in the camp towns violated
the constitution.
Borrowing from the Italian political
philosopher Giorgi Agamben,
I think this legal structure
can be conceptualized as a state
of exemption in that it
represents the undercutting of laws
by executive actions,
causing disturbance
in the hierarchy of
laws and regulations.
Under this regime the
Korean government attempted
to make military prostitutes
into submissive bodies
who offered safe sex to
its most powerful ally.
In addition, the government
tried to indoctrinate these women
with patriotism through a series
of lectures by its officials
which was called patriotism
education.
The regime describes such
a lecture as follows.
"The lecturers were community
leaders and department officials.
Speaking to the microphone all of
them regurgitated the same verbiage.
"Ahem, you are patriots.
Please have courage and pride
and do not forget you are
contributing to obtaining dollars.
American soldiers came
here to help our country,
so please be decently
dressed for them
and do not use such vulgar slang."
Today, we invited a famous
English teacher, Tony Hart."
In 1971 the chief of police of the
district of Seoul and the commander
of the US military in
Yongsan jointly issues a flyer
to the prostitutes to deal with
racial tension in camp towns,
repeating the same patriotic theme.
This flyer stated as follows.
"We believe that you have been
offering the US military the best
service so far.
But in some cases you might
have hurt some soldiers'
feelings unintentionally.
Let's reflect on such
behavior and correct it.
You have to know that the
enemy is taking advantage
of even trivial incidents.
In the same vein, you could help the
enemy unknowingly, and as a result
of that, the national
security could be undermined.
Please keep in mind that US military
came to Korea to help defend us
from North Korea's
aggression and destruction.
Not only for your business,
but also for national security,
please cooperate with us in
solving current problems.
We encourage you to serve all
American servicemen equally."
The toleration regulation
regime continued
without challenge for
almost 40 years.
The first challenge
came from the increase
in immigration in the late 1990's.
As Korea's economic development led
to the depreciation of the dollar,
serving American military personnel
became a less lucrative option
for Korean women.
As a result, to fill
vacancies, club owners started
to import foreign entertainers
from impoverished countries
such as the Philippines
and former Soviet Union.
Being foreigners, these immigrant
entertainers were more vulnerable
to exploitation and
violation of their rights
than their Korean counterparts.
Thus camp towns became notorious
for international human trafficking.
In 2001, the US Department of
State published the Trafficking
in Persons Report, which ranked
Korea among the most heavily
trafficked countries.
As a result of the report, the
Korean government was faced
with significant international
pressure to reduce trafficking.
The Korean government
immediately rebutted this report,
but at the same time it
acknowledged the need
to combat human trafficking.
Second, the growth
of women's movement,
which accompanied Korea's
democratization also contributed
to changes in prostitution policies.
In 2004 Korean feminists succeeded
in enacting more stringent
laws prohibiting prostitution,
making toleration lose ground.
Registration, STD testing and
mandatory treatment which were based
on tolerating prostitution
entirely ceased.
Finally the toleration regime was
replaced by complete prohibition
which remains current Korean policy.
Today I've explored the history
of Korean prostitution
policies for the US military.
Even though I showed you how
oppressive the toleration regulation
regime was, I do not want to depict
camp town women solely as victims.
In fact, they were also
brave women who fought
against the injustices
inflicted on them.
Such as government control,
club owners' exploitation
and American servicemen's
misconduct.
I discovered many newspaper articles
reporting these women's protest.
In 2014 camp town women,
many of whom have now become
grandmothers started a new struggle.
With the aid of feminist
activists, researchers and lawyers,
they filed a law suit
to demand reparations
from the Korean government for the
violation of their human rights.
I hope that this suit
will be an important step
to vindicate their rights.
And I hope that my
research will shed new light
on their forgotten
history and contribute
to coming to terms with the past.
Thank you for listening.
[ Applause ]
If you have any questions, I would
be happy to try to answer them.
>> In one of the later
documents that you showed,
the government was [inaudible]
that they should serve all
of them equally, is this a reference
to racial problems
with American troops?
>> Jeong-Mi Park: It's actually
after Civil Rights Movement
in United States occurred,
and it influenced Korean
government policy as well.
And you know, clubs and camp towns
were divided according to the race.
Some clubs served white soldiers
and some clubs for black soldiers.
And usually the clubs for
black soldiers were not so good
as those for white soldiers.
So there were some
riots by black soldiers.
Yes, so to deal with such racial
tension the Korean government
encouraged camp town women to
serve all servicemen equally.
>> Do you know what
happened in the North,
especially during the
war with Chinese troops?
>> Jeong-Mi Park: Actually
I am not aware of that.
Because that is beyond
the scope of my research.
I'm sorry.
>> Do you know about whether forced
sterilization was part of any
of the programs reinforcing
the toleration regime movement?
Force sterilization?
>> Jeong-Mi Park: Actually I don't
think there was force sterilization
that occurred in the camp towns.
But abortion was usually dominant,
especially by club owners.
>> Let me ask you something.
Specifically for --
[ Inaudible ]
>> Jeong-Mi Park: Well the
questions are very difficult.
So I can't remember the
first question, so I'm sorry,
but could you repeat
the first question?
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah. There is not enough material,
but I know one woman's autobiography
that she was former comfort
woman for the Japanese military.
But after the liberation she
worked in camp towns as well.
But it was just one
case I found, yeah.
But I think there might be
some women who persisted
in so-called comforting
soldiers after World War II.
I mean some former comfort women
for the Japanese military
continued their work,
so-called their work
after the liberation.
Because you know, they didn't have
enough means to make a living,
but unfortunately there is
no evidence so far except
for that one I mentioned.
And yeah, although
prostitution is totally outlawed,
especially after 2004, probably
there is still ongoing prostitution
in camp towns among the
foreign immigrant entertainers.
But yeah, but there are
regulations such as registration
and mandatory treatment or mandatory
examination entirely ceased.
So I don't think it can be called
toleration regulation anymore.
And yeah, today I focused on
the Korean government's policy,
but you know, the US
military also intervened
or assisted the Korean government
to carry out such policies.
So I think there might be some
lawsuits against the US military
or against the United
States but I'm not sure.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah. You know, Korea was
communist military dictatorship
for so long time.
So patriotism was a kind of
universal discourse not only
for camp town women, but
for ordinary citizens.
But you know, the Korean government
passionately emphasized these women
to emphasize patriotism
to make these women
so-called patriotic subjects
to more effectively serve
its most important allies.
And one more question.
Yeah?
>> Thank you for your presentation.
Really, really interesting.
[ Inaudible ]
What was the status of the
children who went to full term?
>> Jeong-Mi Park: You mean
during the Second World War?
>> Yeah, because of
the situation in Korea.
>> Jeong-Mi Park: Or
after the colonization?
>> During the war, yeah.
World War II, the war.
>> Jeong-Mi Park: During the Second
World War Japanese military comfort
stations, babies were
usually aborted, yeah.
And some fortunate women
were able to give birth.
And after the liberation, many
military prostitutes got married
to members of the US
military as well.
So they had babies, but you
know, they were considered kind
of social outcasts in Korea because
-- so they were called mixed blood.
So many of them were
actually adopted
to the United States
or other countries.
It was an official policy
for the Korean government
to so-called export
those mixed babies.
>> Jason Steinhauer: I
think we'll stop it there.
Thank you, Dr. Park.
[ Applause ]
I think there's some thunder
brewing, so we'll get you
out of here before
the thunderstorms hit.
A quick final announcement
though, we are on break
from our public programming
for the next couple of weeks.
But we return August 18th with
a lecture by our Kluge chair
in countries and cultures
of the self, Dr. Juan Cole.
He'll be talking about ideas
of peace in the Qur'an.
So please join us for that.
If you're interested in our events,
please sigh our email
list on the way out.
And thank you again, Jeong-Mi,
for a fascinating lecture.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.